remembering fallen officers through a
scholarship that serves as their legacy
news reporter Victoria Saha shows us how
this scholarship helps heal the
department while also helping send a
dozen teenagers to college
Michael Brandon a hopeful moment for 12
high school students as they accept
their scholarships all while honoring
the men whose names are behind it Igor
and Allen were two very important people
to this organization as are all the
officers that go out every day and serve
this community June
President Ford
's under Sheriff Andrew Walsh's member
three officer Igor saljo and Alan Beck
were grabbing lunch at a pizzeria when
they were ambushed this is just a day
where out of all that darkness and
sadness comes some light
comes some hope for the future hope that
stemmed from the Allen Beck and Igor
salder Memorial Scholarship this year
going to 12 teens of active duty
officers this is my whole career is
about service my dad's whole career has
been about service so it's amazing to
receive the scholarship for that reason
for justice maestus the five thousand
dollars she was awarded will go a long
way as she starts school at the
University of Michigan it really lowered
those costs for me and made sure that I
don't have to take out student loans all
while keeping Public Service on her mind
service and sacrifice it's a life of
service to others so to hear that come
out of the mouths of young children you
know who are off to college who want to
come back and serve their Community or
Community somewhere in this country
that's refreshing since the Memorial
Scholarship was created nearly nine
years ago almost 100 students have been
named recipients Victoria Saha 8 News
Now